Messy.
Do you see a way in which this political epic comes to an end?
The only hope that I have is through reasonable dialog becoming an accepted and
appreciated thing,
a celebrated thing,
and that this is possible that people can realize that there's some,
some stupidity to this team mentality that we have is right versus left,
which is almost all a good percentage of it is he's assumed identities,
right?
These,
uh,
these predetermined patterns that get adopted in order to,
as we first started talking about this,
in order to establish yourself as someone who's in a group,
right?
You get accepted by this group and you see it left and right.
I mean,
I don't want to name any names,
but there's a bunch of people that do it blatantly.
You see them and I've even seen him switch teams and you see them switch teams
and I don't buy their rationalizations when it comes to ideology,
but I think is what they're doing is they're switching teams because they
realize there's an in on this team and they can just say this is the problem
with the team.
I used to be on those fucking losers and they're,
they're really benedict Arnold.
Right.
And like,
like they probably have as much of an affinity to the ideas of one side as you
do the other side.
They just go all in on one side to get acceptance from the group.
It is no way people change their opinion that much over two years or something
like that or you know,
it's like they just decide this group makes more sense now and I've been
attacked by people on the left so I'm going to go to the right or vice verse.
And usually what it is is,
I mean when even when they say they had been attacked like,
oh you fucking baby,
there's 300 million people just in this country alone.
If you put something out there publicly and a thousand people attack,
you don't act like you're being persecuted.
Okay?
You have an idea,
you've,
you've launched that idea out into the zeitgeist and people took a big shit on
it.
You know,
whether it's people on the right are people on the left.
You've got to be able to argue your 0.1 way or the other and not just
immediately jumped ship when someone who shares ideas with you decides that your
idea sucks and maybe they're wrong and maybe you're right,
but you've got to argue that through.
But this idea of these partisan patterns that people just seem to automatically
fall into there are so detrimental to dialogue is so detrimental to us under
really understanding each other and really having some sort of a sense of
community,
right?
This is a giant community of 300 million people.
That's what it's supposed to be.
And this idea that it's,
this group is trying to fuck it up and they're trying to turn us all Muslims and
this one wants everybody to be gay and this one wants everybody to fucking have
free food.
And this and this.
This is nonsense.
We need better understanding and,
and you know the word better,
education gets tossed around a lot,
but it also means better social understanding,
better social education.
I got at appreciation of who we are and why we think the way we think and
calling out weasels on both sides of the pattern,
like calling out weasels on the right that are pandering,
that are just trying to like get the repeating a lot of these like accepted
beliefs cause they know that they can hit this frequency and a lot of people
sing along or the same thing that our people are doing on the left.
They're doing an on both sides.
I think most reasonable people have a collection of ideas that they share from
both the right and the left and most reasonable people are reasonably
compassionate.
And I think that's one of the things that we're missing some,
a reasonable sense of not just ethics,
but an appreciation for each other,
for all of us as a group.
And this,
that I think if we can celebrate reasonable conversations and celebrate and
understanding of other people's perspectives,
right?
Like be able to just look at how you're looking at things and have empathy.
Okay,
let me see where you're coming from with this.
let me put myself in your shoes.
Okay.
Instead of just immediately like,
fuck you,
you cook and fuck you,
you this.
And instead of thinking about it that way,
if we just tried to just everybody exercise a little bit more so we're a little
bit more calm and come at this from a rational place and try to like realize
like w
exclusion.
I've been experimenting with a very dangerous idea,
which is that I keep hearing about chief inclusion officers and you know,
I thought about,
um,
from it,
from Ecclesiastes,
these,
you know,
to every season there is a purpose under heaven.
So if there's inclusion,
there also has to be exclusion,
right?
And like deep platforming or unplanned forming somebody as an act of exclusion.
And very often it's very interesting that the people who are for inclusion are
very focused on the need for deep platforming,
which is an act of exclusion.
So should we have chief exclusion officers that both monitor who is being
excluded,
including,
you know,
somebody like James Demore,
uh,
at Google.
Like is it ethical to exclude him or are there certain voices that need to not
be at some tables in order for something to make progress?
Because if you always have the voice that's the most extreme,
that doesn't accept the game,
then it's very hard to move forward within the game if you're constantly being
reminded,
you know,
so we have this,
um,
we have a series of situations in which it seems like some perspective that very
few people hold terrorizes majorities or you know,
group of people who sort of can more or less get along with each other and keeps
pushing us into this very divided landscape.
And I was just curious,
you know,
in terms of our group of people that we talk and hang out with in common,
um,
where you see the high leverage it is that we're,
we've just finished the midterm,
we've got this 20,
20 election.
It looks to me like Hillary is kind of I and whether she wants to get back in
the game,
um,
this Trump thing has completely,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
it's like the dress is it black and blue
or white and gold for like could be eight years.
Yeah.
And I just have you thought about how this ends?
Well,
I would never be so presumptuous to think that I have any idea how this ends.
Okay.
I have,
I've proposed various scenarios to myself and I don't like any of them.
I don't like where it's going because what I worry about,
and this is,
uh,
also again hypocritical that cause I think it probably should burn down and be
rebuilt from the ruins.
We're not going to get such a clean to be clean.
I know.
And this isn't very clean either though.
Honestly.
It's that guy.
One,
it's not clean,
heavy hit.
This is,
he loves Putin,
you know,
this ain't clean.
You know,
the whole thing is weird.
It's the banker's having the amount of influence they have.
The fact that there's two lobbyists.
What is it?
What's the number like two lobbyists to every member of Congress or to lobbyist,
every senator from the pharmaceutical industry.
By the way,
the number of people that have influence over the way,
our laws are shaped.
It's,
it's so fucking bananas right now.
Right.
So,
so off the rails,
is that what it is?
12 but I didn't type in specifically,
but there's a 23 registered lobbyists for every member of,
no,
I think,
uh,
from the pharmaceutical industry they were saying not just,
I think it's too for every member of Congress in the pharmaceutical industry.
Um,
yeah.
The,
the question that you started out with like d platforming people,
I think we're impatient and I think we're,
we're,
we really want to make sure that this vetting of ideas happens quickly because
we see the answer.
We s we see the solution,
we,
we see that this is incorrect.
And we see these people that think the world is flat,
are idiots.
And we think that these people that this,
I think this and think that we think they're all wrong.
And so we want to stop them from talking.
But that doesn't work.
It just works for now.
It,
it,
it oftentimes feeds those ideas and it also,
you have to question like,
why are you so sure why you showed so sure that you are correct that you want,
you don't just want your side to be heard exclusively.
You want to,
you want to silence these,
uh,
other people's ability to participate in this argument,
even if they're totally wrong.
I think that's dangerous because I think that the way to fight off ideas that
aren't good is to introduce ideas that are good and you're gonna,
you're gonna have a bunch of people that agree with the ideas that are bad.
But I think that that's a part of this whole figuring things out.
Like you need to have bad ideas floating around there to appreciate good idea.
So if all the ideas are good,
like what do we do?
Cut it out against.
It's not bad to have these bad ideas broadcast.
What's bad?
To not have someone say,
Hey,
these are bad ideas.
You need to see the pitfalls of racism.
We need to see the pitfalls of crime.
We need to see the pitfalls of corruption.
We need to see it in action.
I think it's like stock market,
swindling.
I think in a lot of ways it's important.
We need to understand that this is a pattern that people fall into continually
over and over again when they have control over the money.
When they have control over that we didn't move the numbers.
What do I do this?
How about if I tell you that this is going to go down and then you invest some
money and I put some money in your bank and we work together,
let's make some money.
This is what people do,
right?
If they just fucking do it over and over and over again,
should you punish him?
Yes,
absolutely,
but I think it's kind of important to see some fucked up behavior just because
we're not done.
We're still in some sort of emotional and psychological and even physical
evolution.
We're in the middle of this thing.
And I think that bad ideas facilitate comprehension,
like these really shitty ideas that a lot of people have.
What they do is they facilitate a comprehension of why we think dumb shit.
And sometimes you don't know why people think dump shit until you see someone
over and over again that thinks dumb shit.
And you get to see that,
whether it's Alex Jones or whether it's to fill in the blank.
What guy do you want the plan?
But I don't.
Okay,
so here's my thing.
I want a lot of our leading experts,
the platform.
Okay,
well you're going deep
spray paint.
I don't know,
a fucking big a on Tucker Carlson's driveway,
right?
We mean?
Well,
if I think about who the great danger is,
uh,
is it Alex Jones,
you know,
who veers towards tin foil hat land,
uh,
with some frequency or is it the people who were selling weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq as a response to nine 11,
or you know,
the people,
let's assume that you're a reasonable person on immigration.
You neither think that borders should be opened or closed.
Um,
then you start hearing professors say,
you know,
the great thing about immigration is,
is that it has absolutely no costs and all of them are better than all of our
people because uh,
you know,
they're highly trained,
they're highly motivated,
they're young.
You're thinking like,
okay,
what kind of thing has all benefits and no costs.
You're not a,
you're not even entering into the rational description and now we're hearing
like all these trade deals that got negotiated.
Yeah,
that kind of wasn't true.
All of those things that we were telling you that if you,
if you question these things,
you are backward protectionist and you were just,
you were stuck in the old world and you couldn't embrace the new,
yeah,
that was all bullshit.
Um,
what I think is we have a crisis and expertise,
institutional expertise,
uh,
is at an all time low.
Nobody really trusts any of our institutions to be an authoritative source of
ground truth.
It's not to say that everything that the institution say is wrong or everything
the experts say is wrong,
far from it.
It's just that there are almost no experts or institutions that aren't willing
to distort facts in order to pursue institutional goals.
That that's a giant issue.
Right?
Right.
And so I don't actually want a deep platform these people,
but I do have the very strong sense,
you know,
when,
when Ilan came on your show and Peter Teal,
um,
my friend and boss came on Dave Rubin show,
I thought that was quite a moment where this alternate network of distribution,
which is not under centralized control,
started to be seen as comparably powerful and important.
And I think some of the noises that Tucker Carlson just made today,
Ruben about,
well,
hey,
you're doing this out of your garage and you have the freedom to do anything.
And I'm,
I'm beholding to the structure in which I live,
um,
word,
a very interesting place with respect to what is this thing and this alternate
distribution network for,
for ideas that's an policed by the institutions.
And you know,
I think I've been convinced in the last two days that I need,
this is advice that I got from you at the beginning.
He said,
you need to start a podcast.
I think I need to start a podcast and I think you need to start a podcast just
to keep going on,
on about the hop thing until people figured it out just about the hot thing.
But we have to,
we have to return to some kind of stable sanity that I'm positive that the
institutions can't return us to because the,
the institutional interests,
uh,
really have to do with the fact that certain kinds of growth on which they're
predicated,
their existence is predicated if evaporated.
So all of these institutions are extremely vulnerable to corruption at the
moment.
And the,
the real revolution as I'm seeing it is that high agency individuals are out
competing,
traditional institutional structures.
Um,
in terms of mind share.
And some of those high agency individuals are irresponsible,
you know,
and they're like Milo types that are kind of trying to light things up and some
of them are extremely responsible and some of them,
you know,
we'll do a few irresponsible things but will self correct.
And this new world that is being born is a huge check on the institutions,
but it's still largely separate.
Like,
am I right that you don't do a lot of network television?
Oh,
do ain't.
Yeah.
Anymore.
But I used to,
I mean,
that's how I became famous in the first place.
Right.
You know?
Um,
but yeah,
I don't do it anymore,
but it's also because there's nothing fun out there like this.
Like there's no place for this.
Right.
Other than this,
this is the only place you could do this.
But isn't it interesting to you that we still have,
not like Jordan had to be dealt with by the mainstream because the book was too
big,
his affect was too large?
I think his effect on the Internet is bigger than the book.
I think the,
the youtube videos and the debates that he has,
the one that I was telling you,
the recent one interview with Gq,
interesting.
It's really good.
The woman's very smart,
but she gets trounced and it's because he's been
in the trenches with this stuff for a long time.
I mean he,
he's,
he's fighting a very strange fight of dialogue and of interpretation and have
discussion and,
and
the freedom of
intellectual sovereignty.
You know,
there's a lot of people that want you to think a very certain way and use
certain words and say certain things and it doesn't matter whether or not you
are in fact racist or sexist or homophobic or whatever.
This is a weird battle of control going on that it's the heart of it as much as
it is a battle of inclusion and diversity and strengthening our overall
progressive mindset.
There's a little bit of that too,
but there's also an undeniable game that's being played and people want to win.
There's scores that are being scored.
There's points on the board that throwing in new agents,
they have teams going at it and whenever Jordan goes on one of these
conversations,
these video interviews and as a feminist and Jordan Peterson like this is a
fucking game going on.
We're watching a soccer match,
we're watching a wrestling match.
This is Jujitsu there.
They're playing intellectual Jujitsu and Jordan's really good at tapping people.
He's really good at it and they get pissed.
They keep sending in new chicks.
They sit in that Kathy Newman lady and she's like,
so what you're saying is that didn't work either and she just got devastated.
She got rocked and this is what's happening over and over and over again because
whether you appreciate what he's saying or not,
he has some facts that are undeniable.
He has some positions that are based on a rich understanding of history and of
Marxism,
communism and a lot of the problems with
people with compelled
thoughts.
If you're compelling people to behave a certain way,
compelling people to talk a certain way.
And we're not talking about,
you know,
compelling people to not commit crimes or violence.
We're talking about
weird things like compelled pronouns.
And so if I take,
if I take your analogy cause you brought it up,
um,
that he's like doing Jujitsu.
So in some previous era,
and I thought your description of the early days of MMA was fascinating that we
just didn't know what fighting was,
so we didn't know who would win or what systems worked.
And if you think about the mainstream media is like Aye Ay Ay Kido.
Yeah.
Some system that maybe has some valid validity in some very rarefied context and
it comes into general purpose fighting systems and it's,
it's dismantled very quickly.
So now we have this weird situation that we've got this new world of kind of
rule laden.
Anything goes discussions more or less and the mainstream world doesn't want,
like the Ikea world doesn't want to acknowledge that this weird UFC type thing
is happening.
How long does that go on?
It goes on for as long as it knit.
And this is
similar to I think the what's happening intellectually,
and this is one of the reasons why I don't think you should stop people from
expressing these bad ideas is one thing.
Stopping people to say,
hey,
we need to kill black people.
Stopping people to said,
we need to kill white people.
We need to kill,
fill in the blank.
Whatever the group is.
Yeah,
that's,
that's different.
You're,
you're,
you're clearly stepping outside of the realm of civilization and into war and
violence and we could all collectively decide and we should all collectively
decided we should have ethics together.
Like whether it's right or left or in the middle,
we should all decide,
hey,
you can't do that because what you're doing is you're,
you're calling for violence against someone who's not committing any violence.
Can I pause you right there?
I think there's a really interesting point.
Okay.
Let's assume that we know that that behavior needs to be down regulated in some
way.
You can,
you can try to silence the person where we just physically duct taped them so
they can't say anything.
Right.
You know,
we,
we put them in jail.
Uh,
we won't,
don't give them access to the media,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
or we can shame them or we can kind of take them aside.
At what layer of this sort of communication stack?
It's a very good question.
We should,
because I think one of the things that we haven't done is to positively say we
agree with you that the speech is offensive and it is potentially dangerous,
but we think it should be down regulated differently than the D platforming
option.
Well,
the D platforming option,
the real issue is there's only a few different avenues for these people to
express themselves publicly.
Okay.
Right.
And the,
the argument that's really strange.
It should these be regulated like a utility or should they be thought of as
private businesses get to decide what's on their channel,
essentially?
Like it's almost like a,
uh,
a private NBC that everyone can broadcast out if it's none of the above.
What if the problem is,
we're trying to pretend,
is it like a dinner party?
Is that the public square?
Is that the utility?
And it's none of these things.
I think these ideas,
what I was discussing,
that like there's,
there's a reason why good ideas and bad ideas should go to war is the same
reason why,
even though I kind of knew that most Kung Fu was bullshit before the UFC,
I want those guys to get in there and try,
oh,
you got some death touch.
Hey,
come on in.
I want to,
I'll introduce you to a guy,
you know,
this is,
uh,
his name's Cain Velasquez and on,
you're going to try your death touch and now he's just going to arrest me to the
ground and beat your fucking brains in.
Okay.
Right.
But that's not gonna happen.
Cause you know,
death touch,
good luck.
And you let them Duke it out.
And that is the battlefield of ideas.
But it is a little,
no,
no.
But,
but when you do platform people,
that's when it's not happening with you.